I wouldn't bring joking booster on Joel
how are you stage white acting
oh I'm great Moses I'm doing so
fantastic isn't it
isn't it funny the the winding road that
life can take you on last year last year
at this time you and I were getting
ready to star in a Network sitcom and
now we're both unemployed in the middle
of a pandemic isn't life funny how far
the great fall want to talk to you
because when we were on a NBC's least
watch sitcom last year together not this
last year of all time of all time
oh wow I was trying to feel worse and
you did it mm-hmm
it's called sunny side but obviously
people would probably know you too from
shrill that's also on Hulu and the new
season of search party which is on HBO
max our friends over there we were on
arguably the biggest job that we've had
right yeah and I let me be clear a fun
job very fun everyone's TVs in it yeah
lucky lucky we're lucky well I want to
talk to you because everyone got mad
this weekend because a lot of people
went to Fire Island right and I didn't
know how important Fire Island was to
the community and I say that because I'm
an ally until last year right to get out
of the table rage because you wanted to
attend the fire island I yeah had a
vacation to attend to and this is the
biggest job of your life it's the most
corporate job that you and I have ever
had that's not like suits and like you
have to be here high pressure and you're
like can I go party yeah and listen you
kill you don't know if you don't ask and
did I get to do both things yes you made
it in the nick of time I think I arrived
about five minutes early for the table
read five minutes early it's very
comforting to have all these executives
vibe it's early shown lost early on and
and it turns out they were the boss they
were the boss they ultimately said no
and now we're free to party as much as
we want exactly did you have any friends
that when
to Fire Island not not this year I will
say like it's obviously ridiculous to
party in that way during the middle of a
pandemic and I do not condone it and I
think it's awful I say the discourse
around it is a little annoying though
because I will say that's just what
Florida is doing every day but because
it's a dude it's like it's an unique
story I don't know it's it's like I'm
not trying to defend them they should
all burn in hell which we will because
we're gay it does seem a little bit like
you know it's not it's certainly not
unique to our community yeah so I've
been pretty monogamous so I don't what
is what is dating look like pretty -
sounds like grebs but what what is
dating looking like during the pandemic
like if you're on the apps is there a
second conversation that needs to be had
I I haven't I haven't like super waded
into dating yeah I mean I've been doing
a ton of sexting just finding new
crevices of my own body to send out over
the internet that will surely ruin my
career later down whatever is left of it
after the pandemic these are the time to
do it just definitely discovering new
parts of my body new angles
what lighting can do for your penis you
know bring light for your penis yeah
just a little tiny I've got a little
baby ring like oh yeah for my penis it's
this a gross light for it should be
because you should like barely be able
to see it but the ring light puts the
dentistry light every crevice so at you
not doing anything
no no days not not not dating just
sexting there's been a couple of people
that like we've had the conversation of
like oh like we should go and get tested
and then you know once we've quarantined
for certain but like you get to that
conversation and then it just all seems
so exhausting and so you just jerk off
instead it makes it so unsexy when it's
like do you have any ham the virus and
killing people how long have you been
when
last time you went to the store in a
while it's not allowed and so many
people it's like okay would I like to
hook up with Joel or be able to hug my
mother yeah you know sure to put on me
that's a lot of pressure to put on
yourself it just it doesn't seem worth
it but an honor to even be nominated in
that conversation yeah yeah so you have
a game
so you know I'm adopted fun fact about
me my adopt my my birth name my Korean
name is Kim Jun Minh and you might know
some Koreans but we put the last name
first the surname first and I share my
last name with a very famous Kim that's
right Kim Jong mm-hmm
Fame leader of North Korea and what
we're gonna be doing today is a little
game that I call kim joon kim jeong-hoon
or kim joon made out and what i'm gonna
do is i'm going to read a youtube
comment to you and you have to guess if
that is a youtube comment from one of my
stand-up clips that you might have seen
on conan for instance or a youtube
comment on a video of kim jong hoon
riding a horse
okay okay specifically him riding a
horse riding a horse and it might seem
obvious at first but there are some real
tricky ones in here so here we go so
this [ __ ] brutal knowledge unfunny
narcissistic asian sodomite with an
entitlement complex what do you think
that is is that me or is that Kim Jong
I'm gonna go with you
okay that is me that is one line I have
to say pulling comments for this game
was psychologically damaging this is
from Dudley do-right RIT lest there be
any confusion
forgive me on this one folks but I find
this hilarious
forgive me okay I always hate those on
stand up with like well that's what it
is I actually laughed at this I'm having
a little trouble gonna go to the chat
for this one people are saying that's
you tragically no this is on the video
of kim jungeun and to be fair to Dudley
do-right it was hilarious him riding a
horse mm-hmm okay there's another one
kind of like how you celebrate
pedophiles oh this could go either way
I don't know I Kim Jong Un's he's a
monster probably but I'm gonna go with
you again don't know this is from W
Grinstead don't know what he's referring
to but I'm sure it's bad from a horse
this video is insane you're you're
actively under the gun viewership
because people are just watching this
video now this is more entertaining
he's like a male shoot male version of
Amy Schumer awesome kim jeong-hoon
don't need any more than that it was Kim
Jong Jong Un's leather speech here's the
last question this is a tough one
okay well how you answer it okay judging
by all the other previous responses I
will not do well he is so funny
he is also the definition of a
butterface
um I don't know who that appointed lets
you and kim jeong-hoon hot angles big
big brown dango he's got uh kim jong own
you're being kind my girlfriend says
they very hot looking when you were
blonde wow I do remember that that time
when CONTU was trying to sort of test
the waters to see if she could believe
you for me but unfortunately no that
comment was about me somebody think that
her face so offensive but I accept it
stop were together hot body than a hot
base so that's it was this I think you
got maybe two correctly out of all of
them and it is working